a new lgbtq Boutique Hotel is set to
open its doors this summer 8 news now
reporter Mary Jane beliesza takes us to
downtown Las Vegas for a tour of this
one-of-a-kind Hotel
for now concrete flooring and dirt fills
this lot off of Ogden and 11th Street
but Mark Hunter is hoping to Breathe new
life into this building it's marketed as
the only lgbtq owned and operated
Boutique Hotel in Las Vegas Mark Hunter
is the owner of the bent Inn which will
cater to the gay community and straight
allies Las Vegas is the number two LGBT
community destination in the United
States and we just felt that there was a
need to serve that Community located
right here in downtown Las Vegas the
bent in will be fully renovated from the
old Moonlight hotel it is a resurgent
area that is will mix perfectly with our
mid-century vibe that we're carrying
through with our property and the local
area the project arted in January 2020
but the
but the delayed construction now crews
are working to open the Hotel this
summer bent Inn will have 33 rooms a
large pool and Courtyard area with a hot
tub there will be poolside food and
drinks available as well as a pub for
locals and travelers alike that'll kind
of offer a sense of community
destination Chris Davin the executive
director at the Henderson Equality
Center says not only will this be a
boost for our lgbtq community but for
business too it's going to be able to
give those that identify as LGBT a place
to be able to you know work and you know
feel proud and feel safe when it comes
to jobs that a lot of job aren't really
you know offer to those within the LGBT
community so this is going to really you
know increase our economy here in Vegas
at Benton our theme is you do you and
everybody gets to be themselves and
relax and enjoy themselves when they're
here at bid in
and bent in expected to open at the end
of August construction costs to open the
hotel between three and a half to four
million dollars